alors tu dis ouais tu as eu débat dans
ta vie au rejet de faire une interview à
peine down ce que tu préfères dans le
cinéma dans le fait de faire du cinéma
ce qui te plaît le plus c'est qu'ils
transforment un est-ce que tu détestes
dans le cinéma
je n'étais pas ici je ne peux rien
détesté du cinéma tunisien du cinéma
donc je te parle du plateau de cinéma
pour moi c'est le plateau c'est à dire
t'as l'oeil de caméras c'est à dire d'un
pôle public comme au théâtre mais tu es
le courrier c'est à dire que le
telegraph que tu va envoyer là-bas pour
la peau dit pas où tu vois et alors il
faut une passion s'il faut de santé
c'est ce que disait khayat payant et
puis tu y vas et à ce moment là tu te
dis il faut piquer juste de normes
toujours pourquoi parce que de toute
façon on va en faire plusieurs celle qui
sera choisie sera celle du metteur en
scène celle de l'opérateur celle du
cadreur éventuellement même celui d'un
ingénieur du son et celle de l'acteur ne
sera jamais prioritaire
donc il faut que tu te défonces à toutes
les prises et parce que de toute façon
tu ne peux pas une pièce tu peux de
gouré comme ça bon mais tu joues le soir
demain commence là c'est définitif c'est
déjà partir le colis envoyé le film de
toi que tu préfères
or je peux pas je peux pas qu'est ce que
tu veux te disent pas c'est cesser ces
six mois par tous mes films de toi que
tu m'aimes pas du tout celui que tu es
vraiment là on s'est foutu de ma gueule
oui parce que complément à un moment
donné un peu de respect quand même je
peux pas moi je suis gentil je vous en
fais pas je vais pas chaque puis je
rejoins donc trop molle d'être au code
quoi bon justement je jouais au théâtre
j'avais fait la réalité des autres et
j'avais pas tourné déjà depuis plusieurs
fautes et la première fois combien
c'était on offre de tournai souvenirs
souvenirs en disant bien que c'était une
participation bon mais je me suis dit
tiens
j'étais tout contact avec hamid les roms
un formulaire de détourner les souvenirs
souvenirs
en fait et puis et puis on attend on
attend on attend pas finalement on va
pour tourner et j'arrive et à ce moment
là
la borne y avait d'autres qui avaient
pris des rôles dont il sait que bon je
me retrouvais un type comme ça
bon et puis on tourne d'abord le metteur
en scène odieux avec l'équipe avec les
gens déjà ça j'aime pas et deuxième bob
dunn moche à big art mais on n'a pas le
droit de me faire ça je suis tout ce que
tu veux figure que c'est tout ce que tu
veux mais ouais commune et bobonne non
et je n'admets pas ça mais je veux dire
qu'on n'a pas le droit se fout de la
gueule des acteurs jeu des acteurs c'est
trop fragile
on n'a pas le droit de faire ça et de
politesse quand même un peu de décence
le plus grand moment de vie meta depuis
six mois à bord toute façon plus
important des dix mots les uns c'est sa
mort tu as fait un film avec gérard
pirès qui s'appelait erotissimo vrai et
il sort d'une femme tu es folle de son
corps est ce que dans les pme était pas
de films à faire est-ce que tu as
accepté de faire des siennes pas porno
mais érotique brown et porno ils ont
aucun talent c'est qu'il faut faire
parce que vraiment faut vraiment mais
vraiment ils font tout anti bandes en
aurait fait si ça a été bien fait oh non
pas ça érotique disons soft on aurait
fait ou non érotiques dont je veux dire
que sensuelle oui sensuelle oui oui à
tout un acteur un acteur c'est ça acteur
des grands réalisateurs qu'on fait des
films
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le lean
lardy tube abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu